>> So subscription models,
why do they rock?
And is there anything that
people should look out for?
>> Absolutely.
They rock,
because they offer win-win situation.
The lifetime value of the user is
much lower in one time charge.
With subscriptions,
we let users test before they buy and
their trust enable us to
increase the lifetime value.
As an entrepreneur,
you're facing two options.
Make, create your own service or
buy a third party service that
offers the ability to manage
your subscription models.
Stripe, Braintree, PayPal and
others are offering it for you.
We recommend to go with the second
option, because the first one will
create a lot of work that won't
make your product better.
It's a classic reinventing the wheel
scenario you wish to avoid.